hello and welcome to this video playing
kiss kyo GA I was guessing some of those
northern African countries but I cannot
tell them apart
okay I went here for one Sicilian okay
let's go for the Kalashnikov and see if
he and had some particular idea about it
okay this one I'm not sure about this
what the correct move what is but I
think there's certainly more than one
way of doing it it's more strategic game
him hmm can you go opposite g5 you know
or not my blunder d6 probably not a rock
t8 at the end Queen d2 made so he cannot
win a pawn and maybe I should have
played 94 before he plays this one yeah
and probably was an option
when did I already ready to already lose
that time I thought I was playing
reasonably quickly but doesn't seem to
be the case
yeah 94 was really stronger
I mean I think I'm basically okay in
this position but it's definitely not
better for black and maybe with 94 I
think I'd rather be black in this
position
I don't mind the Queen's radium hmm yeah
this is a good movement that allows him
to trade off a whole bunch of pieces
yeah not much going on so much for the
Sicilian trying to get more excitement
then in the in the typically for your
five positions that I play okay this is
actually now a little bit more
interesting so it seems like he's tried
this tries to play for that for the pawn
but don't quite ok night okay if I go
Knight f6 Knight c4 he will actually
trade off everything okay but okay night
c4 I can take if I do this for example
and then f5
hmm maybe I can try to do something here
maybe I don't get it okay
so it's just a pawn down
hmm I was surprising that I just one day
pawn so is it in check hmm maybe I
should have prevented that yeah but okay
it's not big big issue or anything I can
check on see for now or just night
before okay that's just making sure the
night is doing nothing you can go from
them
I can check on CFO and I'd see - but
that doesn't that doesn't lead to all
that much
check
I'm trying to be as active as possible a
g5 coming check I didn't see that check
at all okay it's a bit awkward just
didn't think of it
94 Oh here actually a little bit better
I also have 95 then after a king
deformer 795 and night on CFO I also
would be quite nice DJs
so of 95 is best yeah okay but at least
it seems reasonably easy to play can
also check in time warnings doesn't help
that much
hmm just going over doesn't maybe maybe
it does when actually how does he cover
it very porn I mean matches Vinod
yeah I think I just ridden the airport
don't see a way to defend it for wide
yes it doesn't get to d1 no anything
white resigns
okay so and an end game win yeah I think
there were one or two interesting points
I think I probably played this a little
bit too quickly as 94 was the better
option this makes this night look a
little bit stupid and he has to spend
some time to get possible night c2 in
later and to get rid of my night it's a
little bit more a little bit more
precise I think this is a roughly equal
position and the deep horn is no problem
as usual and white has some somewhat
passive looking pieces so this is about
this is about equal nothing going on so
we had this my idea with this I'm not
quite sure but it's good but I was
trying to drawing badly and she was try
for this activate the Queen and
potentially traded okay went there I'm
Queen c7 big stakes and now he went c5
just trading training in the house it's
interesting that stockfish okay not very
deep not with the very deep calculation
gives a white quite an advantage here
this is this is I'm quite surprising to
me I don't see what's advantage he's got
of course more space but it's that
really important I mean it's giving like
0.7 which is really a bit like black as
in a dreadful situation and I don't see
that all that much the D pawn well you
cover it I cannot do much with like but
still I'm surprised at the end
slice dislikes into so much yeah after
this it gives equal and yeah probably I
think white should just trade everything
I mean this is more its playing more
long playing from asking for trouble
that's what I'm trying to say the engine
wants to do this okay
what's interesting preventing any
operations on c4 and here I think yeah
it's still probably it wrong to equal
but this is plundering the porn and I
just blended the porn in one move yeah
and after that I'm probably not sure
that yeah here we actually what did that
take this I can go here which is
perfectly good also threatening this
that would have been a lot easier not
quite sure check check
Chester is good enough so that it should
win but check I think this protected
passer would have been yeah would have
been better
Jim computer just says I'm winning all
the way so maybe I didn't do it all that
badly in the ending it felt a little bit
a little bit it's wrong to me what I did
but maybe I'm I'm not right about that
okay guys thanks for watching